they're like buzzards circling our
people we're still
[Music]
[Applause]
Warriors I ought to kill these white men
who killed my
family I need you here I am right
here thank you my goodness whoa I think
they liked it I
hope Marty let me ask you this is a long
time coming this is I say sort of
because it's a crime story it's all
different kinds of things but it is a
Western and you haven't really done one
before uh until this moment uh so what
was your inspiration of tackling killers
of the flower Moon well first of all it
was the story and um uh the the the
timing of the story The were the time
the the the period of the story and that
it's something that was a little more
accessible to me than um images that uh
I can't go near I can't go near the
images of a John Ford or Howard Hawks or
Ral Walsh or Andre the tot or bud beter
or delman Daves or any of these guys who
did some of the greatest westerns the
minute I see a man and a horse or a
woman or this forget it I mean I I it's
nowhere it it doesn't come from me it's
not authentic enough for me the American
Western genre finished in around 68 I
think it was with the Wild Bunch that
put the end to the the the the genre
itself in terms of America in terms of
our history in terms of the new
generations and where we're going so for
me when I saw that the that it had uh
elements that I could identify I could
feel more modern I felt less intimidated
we felt we had the ability to go in and
and try to create that world at that
time because it's really the story the
story for me was extraordinary um I had
heard about it a little bit uh but
reading the book David Gran's book and
then Eric script this is something that
I thought we'd take a chance and see if
we could come up with something unique
and original right around the time of Co
hitting is when ultimately Leo came to
me and uh talked about changing the
direction of it in terms of which
character he would play we approached it
from the point of view of the book in
which the Bureau of Investigation comes
in from Washington and they're looking
around for who did it and we look at
each other and we know who did it you
you would know who did it
immediately and it so it became a story
I think David Grant has said this it
became a story of not it's not who did
it but who didn't do it now who it who
didn't do it then you have to be very
original I should say as to how to
immerse all the characters in The
complicity and then how it relates to us
as people the first thing that came to
mind of course was dealing with the oage
and Native Americans in the right way
that was the first thing that uh even
before I read the book I know first of
all we have to know that there with us
on that on this and that they would be
able to trust us and um to try to make
something that is uh uh respectful and I
I don't know as as authentic as possible
when I did visit with the oage I I was
told that to please remember that um a
lot of these people were best
friends uh I was told clearly that from
Margie I think Burkhart that um um Molly
and Ernest were really in love and I
said well that's story and we realized
it's still we're trying to balance Molly
and Ernest and everybody and all these
different elements all these things seem
to be getting in the way of the heart of
the picture and you told me where's the
heart of the picture and I said as a
Molly and Earnest and you said I should
play
Earnest in which case we said okay and
we said okay that means we take the
script now instead of coming from the
outside and We Go From the Inside Out
Leo you started out with one character
in mind and then you decided no I'm
going to do this one Tom white was
obviously the the Gallant FBI agent
white savior that uh comes into
town type of character we read the
screenplay and we besides all the
factors of that being the lead the
emotional core was when this one tiny
sequence between Molly and Ernest and we
read that and that was the moment that I
think both of us felt when we did the
read through that I had this swell of
emotion I said how how could this
relationship exist and it really did
these people
were truly in love and he was
simultaneously doing these incredibly
horrific things to the woman he loved
and that that complexity that Duality
that bizarre Twisted
relationship sort of molded into
something more as we started to have
conversations and we started to watch a
lot of Montgomery Cliff films we started
to watch A Place in the Sun and the ays
the the AIS the ays of Place in the Sun
and then we watched Red River how you
can have you know the American sort of
dream gone wrong this quest for greed
this quest for you know the American
dream and we said wow these films from
the 40s 50s they work these These Old
School sort of narratives and that sort
of all sort of clashed together with
with us we started to converse more and
more and then the challenge was you know
as I started to research Earnest and you
realize what an incredibly unredeemable
deceitful numb skull of a man he he
actually was how do that's why he was he
was not afraid to do that though as an
actor as an actor to play this person
who was really you know uh you know
really really uh weak the truth is the
more we spent time in in oage country
the more like it's it's there's honestly
the ghosts of these people still
existing we were there 100 years you
know to the to the year after the first
murder and the flower Moon came out it
was like like a full century and the
stories are still there the pain was
still very much there and the remnants
of all of this was still very much with
that entire Community then you know
again listening to some of the relatives
you know we we we Tred to do as best to
representation of what really happened
in that relationship as we could amazing
and in the relationship here Lily
Gladstone you saw what they thought of
your performance it is amazing and
um
it's um you grew up uh in the black feet
uh reservation you are um obviously a
Native American coming at this from a
different point of view what what is the
meaning of playing this role for you it
means a lot on a lot of different levels
there's um I keep using this week this
word
restorative um American Indians we had a
very prominent period in cinnamon in the
20s when we were making our own work
people were interested in what we had to
say about
ourselves Great War happens everybody
needs a hero everybody needs the cowboy
Indian Dynamic and everybody wants to be
the cowboy so we become the bloodthirsty
Savages we become the Fate worse than
death all of that so this golden age of
Cinema where this story actually worked
we existed in a really pitiful way so
having Molly at the heart of this
complicated story that could have lived
in the Golden Age of Cinema bringing
that love story out bringing that
character out it was a restorative
moment for film history but so how do I
hold this piece and be responsible to
oage be responsible to my
great-grandmother Lily who would have
been Molly's contemporary was born 10
years after Molly so there was that
responsibility within my own family and
then create a character that oage people
would recognize that they would feel was
theirs because that's ultimately in the
end who I'm handing this performance
back to as the oage nation it was an
enormous undertaking
historically you know history like
American history film history American
Indian history and representation there
and what about working with Leo and
Marty and Robert daero and yeah walk on
the set they have all these
relationships of all these movies and
now you are new
guy
right being in this circle it's so
loving it's so um you know I talk about
how it's not just that a space was
created for me and like I was made to
feel comfortable enough to contribute it
was it was expected that I do so you
know it was expected that I show up and
I bring Molly now this gentleman right
here at the end Rodrigo PRI this isn't
even enough for him to have one movie
this year he also shot
Barbie
[Laughter]
so talk about talk about the challenges
here part of the role of the
cinematographer is to certainly support
the performances but also find ways so
that the camera and the lighting really
represent what they're feeling you know
and I think um a lot of the way that
Marty designs the shots are certainly
aimed in that direction the energy of
the scene what uh what what should it
feel like and that a lot of the
discussions were about that for example
the moment when the the house explodes
and then the moment when Ernest comes
back to the house it was thought
differently you know the idea was to
have a point of view coming into the
house and the family was going to be
there and Marne said where where would
you be where would you be with the
family and I remember Lily said yeah
they'd be there in the living room or
that's the way we planted that's the way
I lit it you know it was ready for that
and then say well in a basement is there
a basement in this house and then I'm
panicking you know cuz Okay now I we
still have to finish on schedule you
know and all this and so locations Bas
they find yeah there is a basement okay
so that became the shot and what that
gave the scene is amazing it's one of my
favorite moments for me it's very
inspiring you know to talk about that
relationship of you know the camera with
the actors and and it was just amazing
working with you guys really thank you
the man that's not here daero is so evil
in this and
so so good and to watch your scenes with
him this is a reunion of sorts on screen
with Robert dairo for you it felt like
family for me in a lot of ways I mean
they both in different respects have
been my father figures you know i' I've
looked up to them and I've obviously
gotten to work with Marty so many times
but it was fascinating I think that you
know they have such a short hand
together it's amazing it's incredible to
watch the two of them speak cuz it's
almost like this kinetic telepathic
communication where words aren't even
expressed they're they look at each
other they go he's like
that and they know and then the whole
scene changes and it's like they're
speaking through their minds it's
incredible you know and every now and
every weekend we'd talk and we'd add
dialogue and stuff and every now and
then I look over at Bob and I look look
at each other and say we don't need any
dialogue no you don't we both agree and
but you know we need to keep working at
it until we found the right words it has
to be done you know and the way you did
it I that's
it that's it and we go from there
amazing achievement thank you all for
coming out here toight thanks guys thank
you